i had sort of a more mild version of his
child where i remember
i would have to touch things and tap
things and
if you're wondering what the thinking is
going on in in the person or in this
case the child's mind i remember
thinking
i know even as a let's say
eight-year-old that this is crazy
but just to cover my bases so i'm safe
i'm gonna do it
so an example would be i'm leaving the
room and we're going out to dinner
and i need to kiss the teddy bear on its
head six times
and if i don't something bad could
happen something bad could happen to my
family
now i know that that's a crazy thought
even as an eight-year-old but i remember
thinking you know what but just to cover
my bases just for safety's sake
i'm gonna do it it's a lot like
superstition like i still won't walk
under a ladder me neither i
i don't think that there's special
forces that are going to hurt him now
but in my brain still i go ah just to
cover my bases i'm not gonna walk onto
the ladder
and that that's how the that that at
least that
obsessive compulsive uh tapping thing
manifested for me as a child
now did your parents notice it like oh
zach's doing that
well yeah they brought me to a
psychology psychologist or psychiatrist
i forgot which one and
and um you know he they they
they explained it to them my mom was a
psychologist so she was uh in the know
about
about it and then uh i think he said in
somebody's you know this whole
he'll be dealing with some aspect of
this his whole life um just
you know but it's but it's manageable
and then i and then i didn't
i didn't think of it in the forefront of
my brain because the tapping the sort of
the most bizarre stuff obsessively
washing my hands that sort of stuff i
grew out of
um um but you know and then and then you
just
so and then i just you know began to
realize that i was a bit of an anxious
person but that just kind of went along
would feel like
the stereotypic east coast jewish
you know guy we were i was raised on
woody allen movies he was like a
the the icon of of of of being an east
coast
jewish american and he you know he was
cartoonishly neurotic and anxious and
and so we just thought it was i just
thought it was part of being
who i was right and now and now as a 45
year old i i see places where i'm
possibly more more anxious about things
than the average
human being do you think you've gotten
more anxious as years have gone on for
me
i felt like i always sort of say
think in terms of i had more energy so
uh you know i was younger my body could
deal with the stress it could deal with
all these things and then i hit a
certain age
and all this kind of added up and
now
uh it manifests itself and then comes
out
in a different way which doesn't feel as
good sometimes you know i don't feel as
confident sometimes i feel a little bit
um just too much on edge i'm a little
bit wound up
the anxiety affects me differently than
it did when i was younger so
do you feel that yes absolutely it's the
same thing i think that
um
it just found a way to peek its head out
in a different way there's a line
i wrote i wrote some of this into my
film garden state um because
it was manifesting itself in a post when
i
graduated college in in a new way
um and i and i was having these really
bad
sporadic headaches and um
i did go to a neurologist and they said
in so many words it sings i you there's
nothing wrong with you and in the film
um the the neurologist um
tells me you know if you don't deal with
some of these things they're going to
find a way of peeking their head out of
the water
and so that's kind of how i i i felt
you know in my early 20s i felt like i
haven't the that doctor as i was a child
was right i haven't really
dealt with any of this in in in any way
and and i don't really know how
i mean i can go to therapy um i can do
things that decrease my anxiety
but um at the time i felt really
um scared and and
uh and and um anxious for lack of a
better word about it and and um so
that was one of the things that that
created garden state it sort of came out
of
of all that